here's a an ancient and very traditional
Japanese toy called kendama ken means
sword and Tama means a bowl and is a
sword and a ball the French name is
billboquet there's that spelling used
okay there's some English versions of
this toy but not so sophisticated as
this one so as you can see a bowl is
hanging from a string attached to thee
this sword has we sent you see there's a
cup here and the challenge is to just
tuck the ball up and then put it in a
cup now that's of course very very
difficult to do so you shouldn't do this
in public and because the chances of
success are very small
even if you'd succeeded with large a
couple you shouldn't try this small
lockup because that's much much harder
to do of course now if you're a little
mad you say ah I notice that there's
some space at the end of this stick
presumably that's not designed for play
of this kind but you know if you're
ambitious you might try and miraculously
succeed there's a place where you can
rest you know
so surely I will not be able to do this
but once in ten years or so I'm and
succeed but what is demonstrably
impossible is you see there's a hole at
the bottom of the ball is to tuck this
up and then make it land on the stick
and it's impossible because you see when
I tuck it up the ball starts going in
all sorts of orientations and what are
the chances that when it lands the hole
is pointing straight down it's very very
unlikely and very very improbable but
there is a trick for this there is a
grand principle in physics that
permeates all parts of the universe
called the conservation of angular
momentum that means that the any body is
spinning once you get spinning has a
tendency to keep spinning exactly the
same way unless disturbed by external
influences not only at the same spin at
the same angular speed but also around
the same axis so we can begin by
spinning the thing and you see that when
I target back you saw that it keeps
straight up because this axis of spin is
vertical and by the conservation angular
momentum once you get spinning it always
keeps the same axis so if I spin this
and try what seems impossible becomes
possible
use the contrast this with when I don't
spin and how much harder and difficult
it becomes I can do it anyway okay I can
reverse the role of this of the sword on
the ball I can hold the ball and then
swing it and try to make the sword
coming to the ball this never works
hang on go on
okay Oh excellent fix it
look I don't live in films yep okay
there are other cups